[Music]
no
the name of the father of the son and of
the holy spirit peace be with
you brothers to worthily celebrate the
holy mysteries we
recognize our sins
is vented
[Music]
the almighty  have mercy on
us forgive our sins and
lead us eternal life
[Music]
marine
view
[Music]
no
o
[Music]
no
o
[Music]
no
here
[Music]
oo
yes no
[Music]
or
[Applause]
[Music]
let us pray
always acquitted your father people for the
renewed youth of the spirit that
as today are happy for the day of
filial dignity so to taste in
hope the glorious day of the
resurrection for the  our lord jesus
christ your son that god is god reigns
count in the unity of the holy spirit for
all ages
there were years apart from post clean with
results for aesthetic use pupita post
clean home I find myself pure cmq sure
vaime start  to a policy and red spears
go there you keep registered by a previte
droid true with ascribed noted trek
ap affixed I take them out for purposes casaca
3 did you can cure the rehearsal dinner
boga in the skies nacho verses box was held
written on sack govi omar triste  that
after verse the canadarm or box of the quickie
v na chang initiative and
canvas spaces from the Israeli derna and the
prof casa greco vette satire domiciled
the iceman yesterday the two cubed fetuses baghdad
and maroni to which tu mo seppuku riad in
apostoli tesa comes from the noise  a
giuste asymmetry his suv edipus
makram atesia the sen and trione rados I
feel there strill.it beasts simeto an
august of the sussan tu go bosis egg
all
[Music]
no
the school with neckline
the stylist vibrates
forest government of I will reveal you
[Music]
almost half from micro
the shield
this school
[Music]
right thorne social vote
instead the stop to the future
[Music]
right rhythm
then
I could not tell him
so
and  he says I looked at agate friend
wood of things
no
[Music] of
course it convenient inhibitors
goes away and goes away that what you don't look at the
qq lent inclusive of testing you
the prot instead 9 million which tucu forex or
plus tasted on guard agnes
the  first you vote the buses and mock the pre
matrouh is in these structures he says
is his avatar
ebook about veneto the foreign circus in the
becquelin assigned hypothermia between the
wall
the circus torchia suv wishes lonia
coitus dina lent in arnesano vv on
venie i test his  arrival says on
old back of ice trita cv nicaso amin
e'toiles that it has to do with testing oneself panatta and
albeit with the channels vesti and v.old
decor tuva and then there is his
[Music]
no
grosso
[Music]
[Music  ]
the spot
[Music]
you are in 87
the man presses and on six avifauna kill
rich real ascom love six years from
home simon pete rito ma nori chambliss
but I am me or coma galilei sco isa you
saw theses  name i drughi dama or tuccini
s  and i fear simon petrin summer break a
drug arrival
what's at stake the arab secam al
aniston is a friend lent to cogato se
vecera susa susa strana da brega
new chinese te ne poznan there is his
enthusiasm for leading brands i married
athens
I fear bobo rite that emerges as the
spa laughter does not love the stands deserves
the only one in love but now for a new
arrival since
the pre-pass spot started at seven cartridges already been
put with isabelle moret now already been
in the tobacconist bars at  blind laugh
streamit is queued iceland
but what is nature and his has not been
private
simon per few the eyes lecce but saturday
8 or 16 gb mabro stop and the city 3 but
look touch the storm if you will see
the sun clogs two huts  as
recorded in the spence da gobbo vita or the
good sites snake ceibos can after jesus
yes but fairy tale in gave sixth and limelight
oh well if instead trenti to whom out of six weapons
but his worries soared the express
nightmares screw
hatched if his maximum
sim  one ions slim code and test tubes foto
via peter mokaba da spogli network udc
his smoke asthma massimo it e hooks
cosmo pastori for simone ioni or vice
suleiman is still casa [ __ ] spogli keys
nyers there is the hobbit his smokehouse
val maximo i tag enza  cosma motrici
simone ioni ovi chat sleiman petersen a
thesis already said three types hole or beachers
women in music
after which he apologizes if
his casbah max tells you the taxis the backrests
schematic kobato well if paul sams and
hope phase iii code if that  said it
was costing pro stress vice the sea
and druks tateo pass ipo see that
said nesta pato launched low-tailed
by himself raspberry crush meter cepros lavi
good player class house mover can
tell you
the ground
[Music]
all
[Music  ]
dear brothers and sisters
christ is risen christophe frescoes
the wonderful greeting with which
Christians in your country exchange
the joy of the risen in this
Easter season all the episodes we have
heard  or narrated at the end of the Gospels
allows us to immerse ourselves in this
joy that gentlemen invites us to infect by
reminding us that in reality stupendous that
mark our life for centuries god
calls god surprises god loves god calls
god surprises god loves god calls everything
happened on the shores  in the water of galilee
where jesus had called peter i
had called him to leave the trade of
fishermen to become
cured of men fishermen the path after
the experience the master must be able to die
and despite the announcement of
his resurrection
peter returns to  life before I
go fishing he says about the other disciples I
am not outdone
we too see with you they seem to take
a step back
peter picks up the nets he
had given up the country on the weight of the
suffering of disappointment even
betrayal had become a stone
difficult to remove
in the hearts of the received were still
wounded under the weight of the pain of
guilt and the good n  news of the
resurrection had not taken root in
their hearts sir knows how strong
the temptation is for us to return to the forces
of before
pietro nets as the outcome onions
are in the bible symbol of the
temptation of nostalgia for the past
those who wanted something back
he wanted to leave in front of the
experiences of failure of pain and
even of the fact that things do not turn out
as hoped there always appears
a subtle dangerous temptation that
invites to the dock of discouragement and
to sars and to fall the arms and the
psychology of the sepulcher that dyes everything
you  resignation
making us become fond of a
sweet astra sadness that like a tar but corrodes
all hope
thus develops the greatest threat
that can take root within a community
the gray for the molding of life
in which apparently everything
proceeds normally but in reality the faith is  it is
running out and degenerating into meanness
but right there in the failure of Fr.  ietro
arrives jesus starts all over again who
patiently goes out to meet him and tells him
simone in the name of the first call of the
lord does not wait for ideal situations and
moods creates them does not wait to
meet people without problems
without disappointments without sins and
limitations
himself but  face sin
and disappointment to go out to meet every
living thing invite him to walk brothers
the lord never tires of calling and
the strength of love that has overturned
all predictions and sun start over in
jesus way seek god always try to give
a chance does so  with us too
he is called every day to relive
our love story with him to
refound himself in the newness that he
looks for us every morning where we are and
invites us to get up and rise again on his
word to look up and believe that
we are made to  heaven not for the
earth for the heights of life did not
speak of death and invites us not to
seek the one who is alive here among the dead
ndo we want it we
go higher we embrace
our most beautiful future not as a
possibility but as a reality when it is
the call of jesus to guide life
the heart rejuvenates god surprises
the lord of surprises who in life
not only surprise himself but realize
surprising things sir calls
meeting the disciples with empty nets
proposes something unusual in them
fishing during the day
rather strange thing on that lake shouts at them
confidence setting them in motion and
pushing them again to risk and
give nothing and especially no one for
lost the lord of the  surprise that
breaks the paralyzing closures by
returning the daring to able to
overcome suspicion overcoming the
mistrust and fear that hides
behind what has always been done so
I am surprised when they call and invites us to
throw not only the nets but
ourselves off the story  there to look at
life to look at others even
ourselves with his own eyes that in
sin  good children to be raised in
death brothers to be resurrected in
desolation heart to console do not
fear therefore the lord loves this
life of yours even when you are afraid to look at it
and take it in hand
we thus reach the third to the same
certainty as today god calls god
surprises because god loves  love and
its language
therefore asks peter and us to
tune in to the same language
love me peter accepts the invitation and after a
long time spent with jesus he understands that
loving means to stop being at the
center
now it no longer starts from oneself but from  jesus you
know everything answers he recognizes himself as
fragile he understands that he cannot go
on only with his strength that he is
based on the lord on the strength of his
love until the end this is our
strength that every day we are invited to
renew the lord loves us to be a
Christian  and a call to
trust that the love of god is greater
than any limit applied one of the great
pain obstacles we experience today
no  n is born so much of understanding that god
is love but in the fact that we have
come to announce and testify to it
in such a way that for many this is not
his name
god is love of a love that loves us
gives himself calls and surprises
here it
is here is the miracle of  god who makes
our lives works of art if they let themselves be
guided by his love many witnesses
of Easter in this blessed land
have raised magnificent masterpieces
inspired by a simple faith and a
great love offering life were
evident signs of the lords knowing how to
overcome  with courage, apathy and
offering a Christian response to the
concerns that faced them
today, we are invited to look and
discover what the Lord did
in the past to launch with him towards
the future, knowing that in success
and mistakes he will always return to call us
for  invite us to cast the nets
what I said to young people in the exhortation
I wrote recently I
also want to tell you  a young church a
young person not for age but for the
strength of the civic spirit to
witness the love of Christ
a love that presses us and leads us to
be ready to fight for the
common good servants of the poor
protagonists of the revolution of
charity and  of service capable of
resisting the pathologies
of consumerist and
superficial individualism fall in love with christ
live witnesses of the gospel in every
corner of this city do not be afraid
to be the saints this
land needs a holiness that will not
take away perhaps it will not take your life  or
joy indeed on the contrary
that reaches the heights you and the children of
this earth to be what the
father of the dream when he created you called
surprised sent for love
[Applause]
next mixed background Saturday 20 near
via legs from mouth
[Music]
will be  my first post collected and minor or
of the film today the covers are expected
or alternatively maria
if we give you a move that I will leave the
sassuolo we laugh but the badger we join
damon between i and harmon secret toad
belts at the port answered you know how far
I can use the breast she is accused of
an
angry solution 396 they are
likely to use her
beloved brothers and children insulting
for the Easter joy we finance
our prayer  god the father we
invoke upon us the benefits of
salvation wrought by christ
[Music]
no
and slay 28 dad francis
before they were in place a Slavic firecracker
ghost of sousse the devout armful
campus of nenia nevi circhiara taylor
busta
[Music]
no
[  Applause]
I made a fight about who justice lmj
a [Musi
] no [M
si
] today
released they want guasco right
whistles or sections evangelion i carmi
i eucharisty youth and dinners explosion 7 with
onfidence the drool eni [Musi
] no [M
si
] o fat
er touches account  love again I am
of the cover es para que del cura a
descent of the 3 races for free will undergo
in via santos operario at my English theaters
[Music]
reach out with your mercy o
father all sinners discover the
desolation that springs from
disobedience to the gospel and let themselves be
regenerated like your children
[Music]
all
indeed future calabria to the future
an an in in fa lei a nil'in  if not to the
transplant data the poet maccanelli
there is my minessi out of shape at school
[Music]
no
but as well as violence o father
our pleas cormaci with your
grace that you grant us to live in the world as
true witnesses of  risen and reigns there
over the centuries
[Music]
no
a little
[Music]
or no
or
no no
yes no
no
enough
[Music
] yes no
[Music]
no yes no
o
no
[Music]
or
no yes no
the forest
of
[Music]
or no
all
[Music]
no
[  Music]
yes
[Music
] yes no
[Music]
yes
hello
[Music]
no
motif
[Music]
no
[Music  ]
two brothers so that my big
sacrifice is appreciated
in a bar of nemi because I
marrazzo
with the ladies the gifts of the fortress in his
head that since you gave him the reason
for so much joy he did not even produce
in a for the tx for christ our lord
lord
our
thanks be born with you out my lord our god
[Music]
really good and just thing our
duty source of salvation
always proclaim to pains and gentlemen and above all to
jump at you in this time in which
Christ our Easter has sacrificed himself that
he continues to offer  for us he intercedes
as our advocate sacrificed on the
cross no longer dies but with the signs
of the passion he lives mortal for this
mystery of the fullness of
paschal joy humanity rejoices the whole earth
that with the assembly of angels and
saints sings the hymn of your glory
[Music]
I don't know
or
[Music]
yes
no
[Music]
to say really holy matera praises from
every cr  eat through jesus christ
your son our lord in the
power of the holy spirit
then live holy fi that the universe that
continues to reason around you a
people that from one edge of the
earth to another or not but in
perfect sacrifice now  please humbly
sent title to sanctify suitable who
preferred so that they become the chorus of the
blood of christ your son and our
lord who commanded us to
speed it up
this insists in the night and then
the town was betrayed the varese thanks with the
prayer of blessings
often the fans  and do not just say yes that
I said take and eat all
those are from the 110 thousand upper classes
[Music]
after the change in the same way he took the
chalice he asked for thanks with the
wine prayer beginning he must only succeed with the
said take and  must put all
this is my blood for the new
alitalia leanza has oppressed for you and for
all in the region or of the three states made
here memory of me
[Mu  sica]
[Music]
mystery of faith ago he wrote nier pro
schools do it to me with inactuated stop
nurse is celebrating the memorial of
your son who died for our salvation
gloriously risen has ascended to
heaven in the head of his coming
we offer you father the return of
thanks to
this living sacrifice she looks with
love you recognize in the offering of
your church
the victim reassembled for their house in
division and then that we deny ourselves of the
body and the blood of our children
gives the fullness of the south in short
because we become one in Christ
body and a sound spirit from katrina
bravi who would like to austrian and go
are moved by envelopes in poverty known
tape sweat and his songs believe it
cisco playing from the ground un po gorica
maria progenie iosif mensa brook street
progenia place liz smith and much begin
the sicis si  the vinegar was there and
raped them dealt with
morientes and toad by stasio milos tv
certainly not from teri he answered me in a
blue sphere ridao kl  epis lavia accruals august
astra moved out serpina marked
cyrus excuse ternary papa francisco sas
man his site and pisco the
cured sausages ferc omnis lusitani
toilet brushes atmar 8 instructs the mules titina flatus and
sad sa passage three themes takes place in hvar
coitus christophe poor by smart a in  a
preview chastity the flag verdes martin
gilot mimos tv today gross voted is
expected kantè verses who has been doing for decades
there is a prize wood in anaste a few in and
meadows sistri the taxman here after having or
if steve a catholic postwoman must be
implemented tarsu who has  said se nadia as
from power to ostia dessena strada as a
Slav there was written nasi and ross rifle
discovered area for written sic kiplagat
because its complex in christ god
father omnipotent in the unity of
the holy spirit common honor and glory for
all  the centuries of the centuries coming to the
word of the savior formed by his
divine teaching we can
say yes no
woods
[Music
] yes
no yes no
[Music]
not only
no
[Music  ]
free us lords of all magicians
grant peace our days with
the help of your mercy
we will always live free from sin more
secure of any
disturbance waiting for the blessed
hope that our savior will come
jesus christ
the south new plan  old lord jesus
christ that the roof to his apostles
I leave peace I give me my peace do not
look at our sins but faith
and your church gives us unity and peace
according to your will
all live in the 11th centuries the
lord is appeared  always with you
a network without
[Music]